cool alrighty oh thank you alright
oh great from flower power hey there my
question is how do you get producers to
read your script I don't have any money
or connections how do I approach this
just try to get lucky that's a really
good question I'm still trying to figure
that out but the one thing that I have
learned is like Hollywood is incredibly
relational in the sense of like because
in theory it's like it's really bad like
I used to always think like okay well
why does this writer make it and this
one doesn't like what's the difference
why does this director not and why does
this one not and like the reality is
like it's not it's not fair like life is
not fair in Hollywood in particular is
definitely not fair and like I I don't
mean that to knock it but what I mean is
like basically the I think when I began
to realize that there are no rules then
it sort of opened up for me of like like
for instance I heard this story the
other day there was like I know this
producer friend who got a movie made
literally because he knew like the
stuntman that worked on the movie with
that actor and he asked for him to pass
the script over and somehow it seems
like in theory that should not work but
somehow it worked and so he was able to
attach an actor to his script and boom
it started got made basically it was
like a horror film or something like
that's right but uh basically it's like
that's there's no like way it seems like
in my limited experience I've only been
I guess out here total like seven years
but three of that I was in film school
so so I'm about four ish years I've been
trying to crack this this thing called
Hollywood but the I I do know that like
you know and I'm very introverted so
it's like difficult for me a lot of
times like get out and meet people
and so I've noticed though that when I
start becoming more relational with
people things start to happen I'm not
saying that like that means like I'm
gonna be writing on HBO next week you
know but like just I've noticed that
every single year I've been out here I
notice more things that make LA feel
smaller if that makes sense so like for
instance the other day I was watching a
commercial and I saw I saw a friend that
I knew on that commercial and I was like
oh I know him I met him last year that's
him he's on TV and and then the other
day I was driving down the street and I
saw a billboard and I was like that's
Billy what's really do it you know and
it's it's crazy and every year that
seems to happen a little bit more just a
little bit more and I know that like
just sustained effort over time should
eventually equal breaking into Hollywood
whatever that is you know I mean and so
like I think that you know I definitely
don't have you know an answer to that
but just from my experience I've noticed
that things have started to happen for
me by interfacing and and hanging out
with people who are like-minded who who
you drive with who like you feel like a
connection with because I think a lot of
times you know one of the pieces of
advice a lot of people say is like oh
you got a network just network you know
but networking inherently feels feels
like not relational it feels very sort
of transactional at least in my brain
and so for me I've sort of tried to tip
it to think like okay well I'm just
trying to find other like-minded people
who I connect with and then try to
pursue that great feeling of putting a
movie on the screen or telling a story
or doing something or you know and it's
not just movies it can be anything any
sort of story that moves people like if
we can find a way to connect on that
then we can become allies and we can
fight for each other and you know be in
the trenches together and and that's
been a really beautiful thing so far
since I've sort of taken that that that
approach you know like like I said I'm
still super new at this whole pursuing
filmmaking career stuff but you know I I
do know that I think if if you just
don't give up and just keep meeting
people connecting with people who you
like and they like you back eventually
something is gonna happen like they I
don't even remember what the quote is
but something along the lines of like
you know the people they get lucky
it's like luck is opportunity meets like
preparation you know like that's what
luck is and so like the more
opportunities you have the more people
that you start to get to know that know
what you do and like what you do
eventually there will be an opportunity
for you to be able to step up and do
something you know and and there will be
long stretches of time where nothing
happens and it feels like you're not
making any progress I literally just got
out of a very long stretch of time where
I felt that way where I was just like
what am i doing out here I want to move
back home I'm wasting my time it's super
expensive to live out here this is awful
but like something twisted something
turned in my brain I was like you know
what I may not know anybody at these big
studios that can just give me a movie
but I do know a lot of people out here
that are on my level or people and I'm
sorry I shouldn't say level but who are
on their same like same progression in
their journey you know I know all these
people and what I can do is I can just
like connect with the ones that I feel
get me and understand me and you know
I've started that process maybe like
maybe like four months ago and like it's
been amazing
like how many just opportunities have
come from that from just like okay well
I know this writer who was in my class
let's just grab coffee and talk to each
other and see how we might be able to
help each other and that's been phenom
like I mean like you can get your script
to people that way you know another
thing that I have a friend too ended up
getting representation because like she
ended up meeting with her friends that
were wrapped by a rep like any person
who was wrapped by someone they went and
met with them and like basically felt it
out like is this a good fit
first like do I feel like I connect with
this person if they did and and
everything seemed right she'd be like
hey it might be a huge ask but like
would you take a look at my script and
not asking hey will you take a look and
give it to your rep just like hey will
you read it and if you like it could you
maybe pass it on if not no harm no foul
and they were they seem to be pretty
successful doing it that way
but there's so many different avenues
but there's really no one way it's
Hollywood seems to be the wild wild west
and I think like at least for me that's
what makes it intriguing of like oh man
the the the next the next thing could
come from anywhere you know but there is
operates there's way more opportunity
around us than I think sometimes we feel
you know it's only just a matter of
focus and attention like if you focus on
the world being abundant instead of
scarce then suddenly the world becomes
abundant and I've I know it sounds
really weird but like I've noticed what
I've made those conscious choices things
seem to happen
you